is this mere gym gal what a boring
episode yeah I know nothing happened
yeah like no nothing interesting
revealed whatsoever I mean no not just
like the crystal gems can imprison
another gem without a fair trial like
it's fucking Gitmo hell I would have
gone with Superman too and Zod and the
others being thrown in the mirror now
Phantom Zone yes oh boy being like it
just ends so that was a crystal jam
yep you're grounded stuff like that I
was like just cut 10 credits what the
hell is that
this is one of ties for the goofy little
war ending I thought was totally
lightened no no that some we need more
than that
so did you water border you're grounded
watch it watch it um yeah well we don't
know if a prisoner without a fair trial
I mean what do we ever see them give any
of these creatures a fair trial well
that's where it gets into the
interesting don't trust them aspect um
yeah that was a shit don't trust them
Steve and I was like this shit while I'm
at it I think it's something to wear
because they yeah cuz you asked me to do
all this stuff and then they're building
up sort of with this mirror and the talk
and everything that like no it shouldn't
be doing this that that's not right just
give me the mirror they're not people
they're not things just give it to me
give it to me and no explanation they
weren't really explaining it so it is
one of those things where it's like
because they're the main characters I
know they're gonna come around it's like
no they had a good reason or whatever uh
but yeah it is what I don't know maybe
the show's gonna take a super dark turn
I mean could be me it's just the one
thing or maybe he can show and then hey
this will see the second sometime you
were the bad guys but it's kind of like
with the with the pet to I mean it's one
of those things where it's like he was
starting to you know almost get through
to that pen and even saves them at the
end but they're like yeah but this still
I need they never even attempted not to
do that and on the one hand you kind of
get it because there are people that are
just so in an environment or they have
to stop to make these things that's like
yeah it's like maybe they try it before
it just never work as
like no this is the way it has to be is
the way the world works but they do very
much remind me of the Jedi and then
that's sort of like but maybe I don't
have to kill my father maybe that no
just ran the laser so down his throat
they'll be fine like but maybe there's
another way Derek oh my cuz it I think
it's one of those where it's like
because they do so much as one of those
just sometimes choices had to be made
and you have to stick with it there's no
way no and sometimes it's just easier to
kill things but I mean that's our bad -
it's like you know it's your kind of
this way or the highway that's way has
to be sometimes you need that but it's
it's not all the time and sometimes that
can really really work against you um
but then again we don't know what her
story is and that's what's so
interesting I just I did I am wow I just
would she's is like you knew it was in
there was like oh shit it's gonna get
looking real right now well and what I
like too is that everything about this
mirror like you know ever since it's 34
one yeah even when it starts
communicating just for showing images
and stuff like that I mean the
backgrounds kind of change it goes a
little more quiet it's like the pacing
cash flows down a bit and it's like it
is creepy it is sort of like you don't
know why but just know something like
something's not right if something bad
is happening right now like something
not good is going down and are you stiva
is so creepy the way it put all those
images together yeah I mean even even
just my sense of mystery to the air
chance it just a little
and the constant repeating of that and
that that's the only way you can
communicate it's like yeah it is kind of
creepy and unsettling um and I got a
broken gem that was the for me the first
tip-off is I'm just like something's
gonna be right with this thing because
the gem on the back of the mirror was
broken up so I just learned what happens
if you break a gem yeah in the previous
episode so I was like huh what and I
think the idea when he slapped
guardhouse just like shit
oh no we both had the same reaction and
it was it was their reaction to one
second before they did we just went
hohoho yeah and then like and then like
amethyst and pearl were like whoo yeah
and I'll say this too it's nice to see
animation because the only time we saw
garnets I I think the third one is just
is in episode where it's just wide open
and now is it it's nice to see like
actual sort of enemy you know like they
all look angry and stuff like that it's
nice to see a little bit more expression
on it
um but yeah it's one of those things
where it's like so we're let's sort with
all these questions and I guess a new
character which is always great I love
when they choose a new character
especially a new threat well you know is
gonna have a bag story is probably gonna
be a juicy backstory
yeah I'm assuming she comes back I mean
what if I can't see how they would just
let that guy me she even says you know
what was her name lettuce lettuce
lettuce so you're asking me yeah I don't
I don't I didn't get it when she said it
it was Landis labs something I am I love
how I love our eyes or mirrors I thought
that was very cool that was a cool like
creepy yeah and I also like I like
because it was like she was cute looking
but also like you just kind of knew she
could fucking kill you
yeah oh but there's also my buddy Billy
but she's saying you know come with me
we're home I mean it's like Jesse yeah
what's going on here oh and let's talk
about the biggest thing they finally
kind okay not the biggest thing but they
do kind of address like he doesn't go to
school and again it is just like a big
how does this work what is going on here
you know kind of the earth was created
in 5,000 years ago by our Lord
is the end this is Sciences like maybe
the gems are just a cult they're like a
space cult Oh God does everybody some
creepy homeschool kid then baby ah you
know a lot of kids our homes collide oh
but ya know it's one of those things no
no there's a nothing wrong with being
homeschool as long as it being taught
you know facts no oh you talk about
creepy I was talking about like more
like a Kirk Cameron's Christmas Holmes
oh yeah like that kinda um but yeah
dinosaurs walk together don't you know
so yeah I mean I thought this was really
intriguing I like even though we boys
we only saw that character for a little
bit the mirror it's like the when she
was in the mirror that was really
interesting even though she didn't talk
and then when she's out it's like yeah
man I want to know this person's story I
just everything about her to seem like
really intriguing and what her backstory
was and he even just saw her character I
mean everything is like wow I can't wait
to learn more about this character uh
maybe we will yeah I did we have to I
can't go in though Mars uh and what's
her face yeah they're broken up finish I
think I I'm not even gonna touch that
one
I mean he's like saying you know yeah
I'm gonna you know okay call some girls
get some numbers and stuff and then
she's kind of making jokes and then
she's like okay you can stop with the
attractive women thing now it's like I
yeah I don't know um living relationship
yeah yeah they're at least friends we
know that um but yeah it just seems to
go right into like you know yeah gonna
look for other ladies in their United
about the love of fried dough I guess so
um but ya know I I guess there's
anything that has mirrors in it I'm
already you know I really get excited
for because I think beers are just such
amazing
here fetish if it exists I probably have
he likes looking at a heads up in the
mirror
um but no there is something about when
people look in mirrors and we can do
with mirrors and just I love the
possibilities with that I don't want to
know what you can do with mirrors Doug I
really don't what they do with me it's
very similar to this episode I know we
need to stop yeah uh but no when they do
an oculus is a great example of that
even it's not good what we but
poltergeist 3 a lot of your stuff they
do is a lot of fun and here here's
another great example of just something
for you can do with the mirror and of
course evil did - yes evil ed - and all
evil does do something with mirrors I'm
fine I'm fine
I don't thinks I don't think I mean just
anything bigger play I think it's just
so great you can do so much with this oh
I love it when I show where movie takes
advantage of that and I the way
communicate I thought that was so clever
and such a clever idea uh like I said
her having the me your eyes I think it's
like what you can do with that what she
can show me she can show stuff to earn
your eyes and stuff um so yeah uh really
good really I don't know like the era so
if I was interested in but this is the
one where I'm like I I will not die
happy unless I know who that was of what
the story was um why in what the gems
were doing with her and why and yeah all
of that stuff like I you know the rest
show it's like if it turns I couldn't
watch her as a champion no but okay like
this is the one thing I know dude I I
got it up I just gotta know what that
was Oh Turkey all of a sudden yeah hmm I
did it's just a shit i couldnt I'm not
complaining I just was like holy fuck
yeah no it was uh it was a good episode
so uh can't wait to see where it's gonna
go I think the next episode is the last
one of the first season um so hopefully
it's a good one and maybe we get some
answers maybe we won't uh but we will
find out when we see you there next time